[Music]
so george have you ever heard that rich
people are evil i hear it all the time
that the only way to get rich is to be
evil
and steal
and be a crook
well if you made money you did it off
the you know it you made it dirty you
had to because every everyone knows
capitalists are all evil
you guys are getting the sarcasm i hope
out there but um i've been on twitter i
know what happens over there yeah oh why
does anybody go on twitter anymore it's
ridiculous but anyway the uh uh
the truth however as we dig into it
millionaires
deca millionaires 10 million or more and
billionaires
have about the same ratio of jerks
among them as poor people
the percentage of people who are crooks
is pretty much just the same percentage
of people who are crooks
and so what we find is the vast majority
of wealthy people
became wealthy by being good people not
by being bad people
so we decided we're going to have a
greedy rich people segment every so
often oh i like that we want to feature
some greedy rich people today we're
going to feature greedy dolly parton
everyone knows how greedy dolly is
she's a horrible person
at dolly's theme park dollywood she's
announced that they will begin paying
college tuition for all of their
employees
they'll want to go to school of course
they'll be covering 100 of college costs
if you work there which includes fees
and textbooks this amazing benefit will
be available to all employees on their
very first day of work it's available
for seasonal part-time and full-time
employees at dollywood parks and resort
dolly you're just evil i can't believe
how evil you are dave careful someone's
going to clip just that sentence out and
they're going to say dave ramsey hates
dolly that's never happened to me george
now let's take something out of context
just the latest wholesale
wholesome improvement dolly parton has
made for the lives of those around her
the iconic country music star has shown
time and time again that she's dedicated
to her community she gave millions of
dollars and raised millions of dollars
for the fires when the gatlinburg fires
happen
she has run a free book program for
children in the state of tennessee for
decades uh that evil rich person dolly
pardon we salute you
we love to hear it that's incredible i
don't know that i've seen something at
this level of evil at this level there's
a lot of evil we should not be sending
people to school debt-free like this we
should not be good to our employees wow
because corporations are never good to
their employees corporations are buying
in
automatically evil just because you said
corporation
that does have a connotation to it i
have a relative that goes it's the
corporations it's the corporations like
it's some kind of thing i don't know
what that means i'm a corporation i
don't know what this means it's a few
corporations it's the corporations you
gotta have someone to blame for your
problems dave and rich people are a
great problem great one to blame yeah
well it's easy to blame things until you
actually know people
you know one way you do away with sexism
racism
and um what do you call this wealthism
oh i like that is you actually get to
know
those people
that
fall in those categories
and then voila
it's very difficult to hate them
that's true it's very difficult to think
they are lesser it's hard to hate
generations lesser than human
if you if you really want to if you
really get to know someone of a certain
whatever category demographic very
difficult to hate people of that
demographic after that if you really get
to know them because they have dreams
they have goals
they have good intentions and the
narrative that someone else wrote about
them
is usually not true
well you know you only you see what you
want to see and that's what happens but
dolly's had a great uh great pr for a
personal brand everyone loves dolly no
one doesn't love dolly
but she's greedy rich people that's
right
but look what money can do i mean it's
awful it's horrible that she's paying
tuition for all of those team members
that's the most unbelievable thing
what what what a waste i might go uh
just work there part time and on day one
just get some tuition go back to school
that's pretty incredible i haven't seen
anything of this scale this is pretty
cool or a seasonal worker joking and
sarcasm aside but i mean it's just funny
and of course dolly is a national
treasure she's his treasure for the
state of tennessee uh we all love dolly
everybody loves dolly and
not everybody because not everybody
loves anybody in this world today i'm
sure there's some idiots finding a way
to hate on even dolly but um uh but oh
my gosh do you think this will be a
trend what more and more completely rich
people segment that's definitely going
to be a trend we're definitely going to
do this over and over more of these
greedy corporations trying to send
people to school debt free you think
that that when there might be a trend of
us exposing the fact that corporations
are not all greedy
ding ding ding cause corporations are
made up of people
and not all people are greedy and not
all people are evil not all people are
crooks just because they have money you
doofus you're offending a lot of people
right now i hope so it's my goal
if you believe that stuff you're a
doofus
oh it's unbelievable man
and here's the problem the thing that we
need the reason we need to have the
greedy rich people segment and expose
the greed of all these rich people and
the horrible things that they do in our
society like dolly's doing this horrible
thing here
we need to expose these things because
what rabbi lapin says in his book thou
shall prosper my buddy orthodox jewish
rabbi
daniel lapin is absolutely amazing he's
so cool we need to get a rabbi back on
the show it's been a while and uh but
anyway he says one of the 10 reasons
that the jewish people regardless of the
time in history or the location in
geography
regardless of where they show up they
have an inordinate probability of
building wealth greater than the people
around them
and he lists 10 reasons that that
happens for jewish people inside the
book thou shalt prosper which is a great
book by the way i highly recommend that
book one of my faves of all times
one of the reasons is is that they
believe
that the making of money
represents service
and so they believe that the making of
money
is is
a holy endeavor
workship
is very much like
worship
in that culture and so the idea that
i believe making money is a holy
endeavor and
i believe it to be highly moral
to
make money if i'm in that culture now
here's the thing
it is in in psychology dr john deloney
could expand on this but in psychology
we talk about the idea that cognitive
dissonance
when you have something in your brain
that does not align
a belief that does not align with an
action
you cannot live in that
in that state very long you'll adjust
either the belief or the action
eventually
and so in other words if you believe
that making money and being wealthy is
evil it is very difficult for you to
make money and become wealthy
if you believe it's inherently moral
it's in line then there is no cognitive
dissonance and so you have this tendency
this magnetic pull so to speak to
in your psychology and your spirit
to go make money because you believe it
to be a moral act
you know if you believe that
smiling is silly you won't smile
but other people believe that if you're
happy you ought to notify your face you
know and that kind of stuff right so
it's this consistency this lack of
cognitive dissonance but and so all you
people running around out there telling
people rich is evil you're spreading a
disease through our culture that keeps
people from wanting and believing that
becoming financially successful is good
therefore they can't do it
it's really a dangerous hope stealer
thing money's a tool it can do a lot of
good it can do a lot of bad you get to
choose yeah i hope steelers are
everywhere all over and so we're here
with the greedy rich people segment to
expose the greedy rich people